des ressources de jours de mer
triomphant face à ses administrés il dit
à leur faire part de la décision de
justice qui après douze ans de procédure
libéra la ville de l'obligation
d'inscrire à son budget la somme de 1
million 500 mille euros
l'histoire remonte aux années 1960 la
station d'épuration de la ville est
construite sur un terrain cédé par la
société ça aide mais en 2007 les
héritiers de cette société rebaptisée
koffi qu'elle l'ait confort galets de
cette oreille vont en justice pour
réclamer le paiement du trm sur la base
d'une expertise qui évalue le mètre
carré à 150 euros au lieu de 50 centimes
d'euros en 2013
la ville est condamné à leur verser un
million deux cent mille euros c'est
ensuite une véritable bataille
judiciaire qui s'engage entre la mairie
les héritiers mais la somme d'un million
cinq cent mille euros est toujours
inscrite au budget de la commune
plombant littéralement ses comptes
aujourd'hui l'arrêt rendu en dernier
ressort par la cour d'appel de
fort-de-france exonère totalement la
mairie de ce paiement
un soulagement une réelle victoire est
un véritable bol d'oxygène pour la
municipalité
ce fut un combat très dur parce que nous
avions affaire à des gens extrêmement
expérimenté sur cette affaire qui sont
des affairistes des affairistes et
qu'ils ont avec eux à l'époque certain
nombre de gens qui les ont aidés
dorénavant nous pouvons mettre en avant
c'est un nombre d'investissements que
nous avons prévu et que la population on
retrouve sa plénitude et que nous
puissions dans une mesure avec l'accord
de la cour régionale des comptes faire
une baisse des impôts que nous avons dû
augmenter un moment plusieurs comités se
sont battus aux côtés du maire d' une
grande victoire pour eux aussi vont à
presque la plus belle des plus belles
victoires du diamant parce que on avait
en face de nous jauger dit j'ai appelé
des démons du colonialisme c'est à dire
des gens qui nous attaquer au plus
profond nous dignité de ne
images nous responsabilité de l'eau
choir qui menaçait aussi les gens dans
leur capacité de réagir
le comité citoyen du sud étaient aussi
parties prenantes de ce combat un
remerciement très spécial a aussi été
fait un citoyen de la commune monsieur
charles virassamy qui s'est démené qu'au
real pour trouver les preuves qui ont
permis à la commune de gagner ce procès